ladies and gentlemen mr. Patrick Swayze
quite a few years ago I figured a
dancing was like totally out of my life
I'm an actor right well I was wrong I
guess it shouldn't surprise me because
uh I've been dancing from just about the
time I could walk and you could say that
I learned dirty dancing from Gene Kelly
Fred Astaire and a whole slew of other
people and my mother being a dancer and
choreographer would put me as a baby in
an empty theater seat and I watch what's
worked well musical comedies were my
pacifiers I was raised on them I studied
them and eventually performed in them
so besides stars and people who starred
in the great movie musicals with my
heroes they were forced to be good at
everything singing dancing comedy drama
the challenge few actors have to face
today but in the 1950s every time you
turned around there was an explosion of
talent and that talent created magic
magic the most wonderful and seducing
ingredients of show business it's enough
to make you leave home for these
magicians definitely had a hand in
seducing me imagine having such
wonderful composers to work with it's
incredible but a good music score can
heighten your appreciation of a film
unlike any other single element the
nominations this year for Original Score
will be played by the ten-time Oscar
nominee and three-time Academy Award
winner conductor Marvin Hamlisch
the nominees are John Williams for the
accidental tourist
Jorge spittin for Dangerous Liaisons
Maurice char gorillas in the mist
Dave Grusin
for the Milagro Beanfield war hans
zimmer for Rainman
and the Oscar goes to Dave Grusin for
the Milagro Beanfield war
I'm sorry but the Gadda me congratulate
stay person and accepts on his behalf